hey guys you ever get bored at home
not sure what to do get off your couch
and start a hobby it's going to help you
not to be lazy
and it's also going to show you that
life can actually be
a lot of fun all you need to do is find
things
that you love that you're passionate
about and do it
so in this video i'm gonna show you 20
hobbies
that you can choose from let's get to it
[Music]
but mistakes make you strong now just
very quick
if it's the first time that you're here
i'm daniel welcome to my channel
and if you haven't subscribed yet please
consider it so you won't miss any
of the next videos now let's start
with the first hobby my favorite hobby
[Music]
fishing for me it's only fun if i
actually catch
fish i love deep sea fishing the most
but rivers and lakes can also be
a lot of fun just like anything in life
the more you do it the more you learn
about it
the better you get so the easier it
becomes to catch fish
you can try bait fishing spinning
fly fishing or
trolling
car restoration most guys love cars
so why not get into car restoration my
favorite is
old vintage and classic cars but you can
get into whatever
you prefer so if you got the space in
your garage or
backyard why not give it a try
you might be more artistic than you
actually think
and there are different types of
photography that you can try
like nature photography portrait
photography
fashion sports
editorial architectural
still life and
food photography me personally
i would definitely prefer nature
photography
bowling one of the things you don't know
about me is that i
love bowling you can join a club and do
it more seriously
or you can just do it every now and then
when you feel like okay
it's time to just get out of the house
and then you do it
the more you play the better you get
metal detecting this is something that
i've always wanted to do
but just never really got to it but i
think it's perfect especially if you
just want to
get out of and away from people just to
be alone put your headset on and you're
just out there searching
and you never know you might find some
treasure
become a spotter in the old days people
used to do a lot of train spotting
but you can also focus on other things
like
birds or trees all you gotta do is grab
a notebook
get to know the birds and trees and then
get out of the house just go and do it
and just relax and
focus on it the older you get the more
you're gonna appreciate it and you're
gonna see the world
in a different way
get into cooking no
i'm not a big fan of making a lot of
food for a lot of people
but i do love baking healthy bread
but if you get into cooking there's
actually a lot of methods that you can
try
like stewing poaching
frying grilling
roasting steaming
simmering braising
blanching and broiling
you will always need to eat every day
of your life so why not just teach
yourself
how to make delicious food for yourself
and then for the rest of your life
you can eat delicious food
play a musical instrument
there are so many instruments that you
can choose from like
drums piano guitar
saxophone trumpet
cello accordion
flutes clarinet
harp my favorite the violin
it's going to take some time to actually
learn how to play it well
but at the end it's gonna be worth it
start working out you can stay in shape
by going to the gym or
just doing home workouts you can't
change your genes but you can
change your body working out will not
just give you a fit and healthy body
but it's also going to change the way
you think it's going to teach you
self-discipline and also just to
really take good care of yourself
online investing this is something that
you can
just test and try out and if you don't
know a lot about it then just start with
the basics at
investing a little bit of money into the
stock market there are also a lot of
different apps that you can
download that will help you with it now
don't go investing all your money or
a lot just a little at the start just to
learn the ropes
[Music]
reading when i was younger i did not
like
reading at all for me it was like ugh
boring
but then when i was around 18 i read a
book that changed
my life and that actually showed me that
hey books are actually
awesome there's a whole world in a book
i'm afrikaans right so the book that
i've read was
krieger and a boss it's about this guy
that needs to survive in the bush
there's also some
elephants in it but it was a great book
teaching me
that reading books can actually be a lot
of fun
so get a book and read something you
like maybe a true story
adventure fantasy or
a crime thriller just get reading
start the blog or youtube channel even
why not
that's what i asked myself when i first
wanted to start even some of my family
members did not believe in me and said
oh man this is not gonna work
but i still did it so if you can bring
value
into the world that we live change lives
if you have something to say
to make a difference then why not do it
we all had to start somewhere i had to
start somewhere
i started with just one subscriber and
now
i have two youtube channels and i do it
full time
and it's fun
diy today we have platforms like
youtube and we can learn how to do
basically
almost anything especially diy projects
to start building repairing
and modifying things yourself without
asking
for help
home brewing you can start to make your
own beer or kombucha
at home it's fun to experiment with
different tastes and to make something
special that you like learn
car maintenance to be honest
i'm not great at car maintenance my dad
never really taught me
but i can always learn myself and so can
you
and at the end in the long run it's
gonna be worth it
because you're gonna save time and money
gaming there are a lot of games out
there that are fun different types of
games but stay away from those weird and
sick games just do the ones that are
healthy get together with a few friends
and play
you don't even have to be in the same
house you can just do it online
you can try mmo massively multiplayer
online
fps first-person shooter games
rpg role-playing games
and then also sports that's a lot of fun
just don't get addicted
self-defense classes this is an
important one because
there are always going to be those weird
and crazy people out there that are just
going to want to start
a fight with you or someone who might
just want to rob you
and you will need to know how to defend
yourself and your family
or you can even get into a sport that
will help you of it like
boxing
[Music]
join a survival school this is still on
my to-do list
because i want to go and try to survive
in the wild for a few days
just living off the land if you want to
do something like this too then
you will need to learn a few survival
skills
like building a shelter starting a fire
animal tracking fishing
and foraging
try a sport like golf i always thought
golf is
boring you know when you look at it on
the tv and they just hit the ball and
they go
it was so boring for me until i was
actually forced to play it
i wanted to marry my wife i had to play
with her father to ask for permission
but i had to do it a few times so he
could
just test me out see what kind of guy i
am so he taught me how to play golf
and it was actually a lot of fun i'm not
great at it but it's fun
astronomy get a telescope and learn more
about the stars
all the different planets and
constellations this is truly something
that will show you how amazing
all of creation really is and how small
we are guys the world is huge and
there's so much
to do so don't just sit at your home
feeling bored
go and enjoy life and watch more of my
videos like
like this one to enjoy life even more
i'll see you guys next video
cheers